hey guys welcome back to the just pearly
things channel i'm jess and this is
pearl welcome back to the journey um
today what is the video that we're gonna
do so we are reacting to ben shapiro
yay
internet history destroying pierce
morgan only the conservatives in the
chat
know the significance of this video
i'm a little nervous but what's new
what's new but before we start the video
make sure you like comment and subscribe
to the video and also sign up for
memberships for some exclusive behind
the scene content
also guys
if you have watched two or more of my
videos and you don't subscribe we got
beef
big b
if you don't want beef subscribe okay so
what's your opinion on gun control let's
just get right to it
i uh
should guns be illegal
yes okay like 100 all guns
i think that only
people who
need them should have them how do you
determine who needs them
if
i don't know it's okay i'm not
it's just a conversation
i will don't tempt me
nah i think
it's it's hard to say
based on what has been going on in
america and you see other countries who
don't have
guns legalized and but you see deaths in
different ways and so it's just like
it's hard to say
who
who needs it who doesn't need it but i
don't think that anybody and everybody
should be able to
get a gun or should be able to purchase
one for a minor i want to be like oprah
and give everyone guns like you get a
gun you get a gun i swear to god
that's europe
because you know here's the thing here's
the thing right if you make them illegal
then people
can still buy them illegally so that the
only people you have getting guns are
the people that shouldn't have got like
the most
shouldn't have guns yeah that's i
thought what if what if we're walking
home alone at night and we get attacked
i'm trying to shoot a person
i don't know
all right so so anyways this is a
british man who's anti-gun yes and this
this interview made ben shapiro's career
really yes okay let's put him on the
back
how strong was for me he says i'm off
the rails on guns in america ben shapiro
is editor at large breitbart.com and the
author of bullies however less culture
of fear and intimidation silences
america so why am i off the rails mr
shapiro uh you know honestly pierce
you've kind of been a bully on this
issue because what you do and i've seen
it repeatedly on your show i watch your
show um and i've seen it repeatedly what
you tend to do is you tend to demonize
people who differ from you politically
by standing on the graves of the
children of sandy hook saying they don't
seem to care enough about the dead kids
if they cared more about the dead kids
they would agree with you on policy i
think we can have a rational political
conversation about balancing rights and
risks and rewards of all of these
different policies but i don't think
that what we need to do is demonize
people on the other side as being
unfeeling about the about what happened
in santa
i will say that i agree with him on that
so far um
i do feel like people if they don't if
you don't agree with them or if you
don't stand on the side that they stand
on they demonize you and they just
dislike
oh what's the word
um
discredit whatever you say instead of
listening to you and hearing you not
hearing what you have to say he's coming
in hot in me
i mean it is benjamin what do you expect
he's not gonna come in sweetie go come
in guns blazing
i feel like everyone's not ready like
he's this is what he's young in his
career what you did this video this was
like 27 2013. look at it
yeah so this is almost 10 years ago so
he was just getting started i think the
people just were not they would be ready
for someone
yeah
dare you accuse me of standing on the
graves
of the children that died there how dare
you i've seen you do it repeatedly
pierce
like i say how dare you i mean you can
keep saying that but you've done it
repeatedly what you do and i've seen you
do it on the program is you keep saying
to folks that if they disagree with you
politically then somehow this is a
violation of of what happened in sandy
hook and you have yet i i really like to
hear your policy prescriptions for what
we should do about guns because you say
that you respect the second amendment
and you know i brought this here for you
so that you can read it it's the
constitution
and i i would really like for you to
explain to me what you would do about
guns that would have prevented what
happened in sandy hook if you want to do
what you did in the uk right which is
banned virtually all guns that is at
least a fair argument and we can have a
discussion about whether that's
something that we ought to do i've made
it very clear what i want to do which is
exactly what mark kelly wants to do and
in fact rather than address let's talk
about that rather than address your
comments to me
about uh standing on the graves of
children at sandy hook you can address
them to mark kelly because he agrees
with everything that i've been saying
because he feels the same way as does
his wife think
but
pierce he's not talking to me kelly he's
talking to you sir
so are you going to address it what he
has to say i don't even know who mark
kelly is who's mark sir he's mark mister
what does he have to do with this
conversation pierce deflecting this
deflecting um yeah
well you know what's crazy though
people looked at pierce as more left 10
years ago and they look at him as right
now because the left has just gone so
far left
wow that's very interesting
like because the left used to be about
like unions so there was a lot of union
orchids that could relate but now
they're trying to call men women
ah and they're doing all this like wild
[ __ ] that doesn't resonate with a lot of
people
okay i i have i have heard that that um
people who typically
follow or follow the left are leaning
more towards either the middle being
neutral
or um
not agreeing with everything that the
left side does i saw that a lot with
this last election that a lot of them
were like i'm either going to
vote this way or vote in the middle or
just vote for people who
agree with my like standards more it's
very
very interesting
gun owners they both respect the second
amendment of the constitution they don't
want to take away anybody's right to
defend themselves with guns now they
want to take away certain types of guns
they want to take away assault weapons
which are capable with magazines that we
saw at aurora and sandy hook of
unleashing
uh a ridiculous amount of well this is a
question i wanted to ask you pierce
because i've seen you i've seen you talk
about assault weapons a lot and i've
seen mark kelly talk about assault
weapons the vast majority of murders in
this country that are committed with
guns are not committed with assault
weapons they're committed with handguns
so are you willing to ban handguns in
this country across no that's not what
i'm asking for when he says in this
country
he's in the uk right now are you talking
about america yeah because this one do
you remember sandy hook yes they're
talking about sandy okay okay okay he
said this country and yeah
so he's asking like what policy would
have prevented sandy hook gotcha
just got me okay
let me ask you don't you care about the
kids who are being killed in chicago as
much as the kids in san diego yes i do
then why don't you care about about
banning the handguns in chicago no we'll
come to that let me ask you this let me
ask you this
what was the weapon used in aurora in
the movie theater it was in yeah
he's
he's firing this stuff off
piers is like hold up wait
let's go back to what you said first
like i can't take all this he's
literally like firing this stuff off
that's one thing i do like about ben
is
if you are not ready for an interview
with him a conversation with him a
debate he's going to fire stuff off at
you like just facts facts facts facts
facts and like debunk what you said real
quick and if you aren't on your toes you
don't be knocked you're going to be
knocked right on your butt
that's the thing in a debate the best
one of the best things you can do and
sometimes i don't do this as much as i
should is ask a question
like i asked the other day on the show
what is name one standard double
standard that doesn't benefit women
outside of body count
and it was just cricket
that was quick wow
they're like i can't
so you said name one
double standard that doesn't benefit
women outside of body count
well being a woman is good
oh that's off topic but i let's like
what my favorite thing about his debate
styles he just asks questions so quick
and if you like i said if you're not
if you don't already have what you want
to talk about in your brain
and stuff that can counteract someone
like ben you you won't you won't survive
it was an assault rifle sure okay what
was the weapon used in the oregon
shopping mall i believe he's an assault
rifle correct what was the weapon used
as sandy hook is an assault rifle what
was the weapon used at the incident
around christmas when the firemen were
lured to their deaths in new york state
finally and bought illegally that was it
that was that was an assault rifle so
the last four mass shootings in america
were all the assault rifles and the vast
majority of that is the reason mr
shapiro and you can smirk at me and you
can laugh at me
and you can accuse me of standing on the
graves of dead children
but that is the reason that people like
me and mark kelly and gabrielle giffords
want to have assault weapons like that
removed from civilian hands your passion
on the issue doesn't really justify the
the rationale for why you want to ban
assault weapons but while we want to
remove the preferred weapon of choice
these killing machines well i would like
you the hands of deranged young man all
i'm asking is for you to be
philosophically consistent if what
you're worried about is the removal of
killing machines from the hands of
deranged young people then maybe we
should talk about a blanket gun ban and
let's get to what the left really wants
here and the you know you say that
you're forced
all right because in britain this never
is about left or right this issue why is
it here well you know we can talk about
britain in a second i think the reason
that it's about left and right here is
because fundamentally the right believes
that the basis for the second amendment
and they believe in the second amendment
the basis for the second amendment is
not really about self-defense and it's
not about hunting it is about resistance
to government tyranny that's what the
founders said and that's what the right
believes in this country which tyranny
are you fearing yourself i fear the
possibility of a tyranny rising in this
country in the next 50 to 100 years let
me tell you something piers the fact
that my grandparents and great
grandparents in europe didn't fear that
is why they are now ashes in europe so
this this kind of leftist revisionist
history where there's never any fear of
democracy going usurpatious or
tyrannical it's just that that's your
decision but to clarify your position
then the answer to sandy hook as it was
to aurora as it was to gabrielle givers
as it was to columbine virginia tech is
you do nothing is that your position and
that's not my position
my position is that we have to calibrate
laws that are designed to get hands-on
guns out of the hands of bad people and
keep guns in the hands of good people
who want to buy them this idea
versus how do you do that well i think
one of the ways that you do that is by
better screening for mental illness i
think that you do better background
checks was adam lanza's mother a good
person uh i don't know do you understand
what he's talking about when he's
talking about government tyranny being
the main reason that conservatives want
gun control no i actually do not i was
trying to understand when he was saying
that but i was like hey oh really you've
never heard that like in history no you
see this is california schools no
michigan
michigan's like that too
i'm just playing everything
so now the reason that conservatives
want guns is it like
even for protection the reason well it
sort of is the reason is in case
across history governments have gotten
too much power and too much control okay
and he's jewish right so he's talking
about in germany one of the things they
did before they took over was they
banned guns
because then if you're attacking people
or exerting government control they have
no way to protect themselves
so the reason that america is founded on
like people being able to have guns is
if the government ever gets too much
power
and tries to pull some like north korea
type [ __ ] everyone is armed and able to
protect themselves
okay
i still like okay so let's let's take
the jewish example okay it the holocaust
right that's that's that's an example of
the government getting too much power
okay concentration camps let's say
america wanted to do that but every
single person is armed
would it be a little would it have been
more difficult to do that if every
single jew was armed okay
and so that's that's the main reason
that conservatives believe in guns it's
because
we we want to protect ourselves from the
government
okay
but then
if that's if that's like the sole reason
is um
people want to protect themselves from
the government
why is there so many
cases where
they're using it in like a different way
well i mean people want them for other
reasons on an individual level
as a whole the main reason that we
believe that there shouldn't be gun laws
is because we should be able to protect
ourselves by any means necessary from
the government
so if i want to get a big piece of land
and get like a what do you call it a
african bazooka
like legally i should be able to because
why does the government get to tell me
what i get to do to protect myself like
why do they have the right to do that
but the government could also
see that
it's okay speak yourself speak yourself
what if everyone has this mindset like
oh
let's uh
get guns to protect ourselves from the
government what if the government's like
ain't nobody having guns and like makes
a law then how
that that there's no guns yeah oh god
people would move people throw
like people would throw a fit but even
if they had a blanket gun ban people
would still get guns illegally oh i i
understand that people still get other
things that are illegal yeah
but like why why shouldn't me a
law-abiding
citizen
and let's say i'm in a really
screwed up neighborhood right that's
super dangerous if i want to get an
automatic semi-automatic weapon yeah so
if anyone knows they step into my house
i'm blowing their head off
legally as a as an american i should
have the right to do that
and because again as a rich person like
my parents can just hire someone yeah to
hold the machine gun
why why do the rich people get that
benefit but poor people can't
i can i can understand that and so and
so if in the holocaust example
if they if the germans
came into the door and all the jews had
stopped punches loaded
yeah imagine like imagine the government
trying to take over texas
oh good luck
good luck nobody leaving that or you say
the lie even some of the the
like bad areas where everyone's got guns
good luck they ain't leaving their life
but i can i can definitely understand
that i just wish um and i think he'll
get to this in the video there needs to
be more
more things
behind it
to
say okay you're fit to carry a gun we
know that you're not gonna
fire them off at anybody
or in any situation where
you're not able to like logically like
think and you just say oh and fire all
crazy so i do think
that there needs to be that yeah i agree
kind of like oprah
i think crazy people shouldn't have guns
oh yeah but but let's say let's say we
made it super easy for people to get
guns right and i'm not saying we should
make it crazy easy but let's say
hypothetically we went to the extreme
what would happen
everybody
everyone would have guns yeah so do you
think crazy people will think twice
imagine okay with the school shootings
if they knew all the teachers were armed
and don't give you wrong that goes with
a whole other set of problems right kids
getting a hold of the guns but no my mom
grew up in rural wisconsin people would
bring their guns to school
yeah they try to shoot the school good
luck
good luck wish you luck
a bunch of farmers yeah oh cause you're
gonna get shot 20 times before you could
shoot one kid before you even take a
breath yeah
yeah and so it's like because when you
make it illegal what incentive you give
it to you give
you punish the people that want to do it
legally yeah and you reward the people
that want to do it illegally because now
they're an advantage they're the only
ones with guns
i can i can see your point there
we'll be talking facts on this channel
do you i feel like you're holding back a
little bit is it my brains my brains oh
my gears are turning there we go yes
my brain is going to be much but it's
weird because as it's like people don't
understand what conservatives mean when
we're talking about this
that that goes with a lot of things
conservatives talk about they just
from my
point of view is like when conservatives
talks like don't listen to them they're
crazy you shouldn't listen to what
anything they have to say
but it's like when you sit down and talk
with someone that is conservative you're
like okay now i i could see how we'd be
making sense we'd be making sense sorry
let's if you're a mentally ill person
does she well no it's not a matter of
it's not a matter of morally because
you're accepting the criteria good and
bad so is she good or bad you're right i
should have said responsible versus
irresponsible that's correct okay so she
goes from good to bad no she goes from
responsible to irresponsible
let's take a break let's come back and
talk more about this because we don't
agree
it's laughs
i feel like
ben
he
i don't
there's just like a demeanor about him
he's just like i'm gonna hit you with
facts and if you don't agree
he's like i'm not smiling i think that's
just ben's face to have that like little
like smurf con
and just like it i think it irritates
people when he's like spitting in fact
he just like
that would irritate me i was like stop
smiling what are you smiling for he's
like
he destroys people
i always feel bad when i do that i chose
i'm like it's okay
just hitting my
i'm sorry
it is what it is
the facts are facts
do you believe that uh
if you had an assault weapon
ban statistics prove that you could dry
up the supply of these guns are made
unless accessible to criminals um i
don't know whether you could make them
less accessible to criminals let's
assume that's the case that you could
make them less accessible to criminals
again my question remains for your peers
and i'm still waiting for an answer from
the left on this they say the pro second
amendment why don't you want to ban
handguns if you really want to solve the
quote-unquote gun violence problem in
america go after all the guns why just
stop yourself at assault rifles because
i believe and respect an american's
right under the second amendment of the
constitution that you kindly brought in
to defend themselves with a handgun or a
pistol what i don't understand most of
the murders are committed with those
weapons what i don't know as we just
established i've talked to you through
them the last four mass shootings in
america adam lanza had two pistols on
him he was just having an assault rifle
he hadn't had the assault rifle use them
as you know and if he hadn't had the
assault rifle he wouldn't have used them
explain to me this i can't buy this this
is six packets of suit effects one of
the many companies that make this
particular uh ingredient
which you can't buy legally
i've watched this interview so many
times i've never got that i said oh are
we gonna cook the mess and then he has a
little some work on his face like
you can tell he's so impressed with
himself i would be too
i wonder how long he like sits down and
does research for something he's like i
know everything about everything you can
tell he used to be a lawyer oh really oh
okay that's why he's like he has secret
websites he can use the pull-up
information
i don't know do they i feel like lawyers
have websites upon websites they can
pull up information and know
exact stats
on everything
in that quantity in walmart say but i
can buy an ar-15 military-style assault
rifle the assault rifle he wouldn't have
used explain to me this i can't buy this
this is six packets of suit effects one
of the many companies that make this
particular
ingredient which you can't buy legally
in america there we are six packets that
is illegal for me to buy in that
quantity in walmart say but i can buy an
ar-15 military-style assault rifle i can
then as we saw with uh holmes the
shooter in aurora going at 6 000 runs
that's one thing i've noticed
when
well in the videos that we've watched
when someone is
speaking and they don't necessarily
agree they won't let them get their
words across but i've only seen it
in
the ones where an american is talking to
an english person
so um
like the jordan peterson ones and then
this one because we've only seen a few
of them and it's like not saying
anything about british people but i've
noticed that they don't they don't let
them finish their
their thoughts on one thing and they'll
be like answer this question or i'll say
something completely different it's just
like it's called moving the goal post
people do it all the time on my show
yeah yeah so watch like this is what
people do when they're losing an
argument one they'll argue an exception
to the rule which we see all the time
yes let's talk about the exception no
okay
and the other thing they'll do is
they'll move the goal post
so
instead of so and like ben is trying to
say okay what policy are we debating and
he keeps trying to move it all over
and you see people do this all the time
in my show when i say like name one
double standard that doesn't benefit
women well there are women that are dead
enough
but like he's doing the that wasn't the
question yeah and it's the same thing
with the jordan peterson video she kept
trying to move the goal post
i think the ones that have largely been
removed from the market fully automatic
weapons would be would be a good start
um i think that you wouldn't remove any
semi-automatics at all no because
semi-automatic just means that when you
pull the trigger once one bullet comes
out you understand how specific
essentially do you understand how an
ar-15 performs when it's being modified
and as a magazine i started in the north
hollywood shootout you know what it was
illegal to do that and people did it
anyway we have we have 12 million
illegal immigrants in this country we're
not able to stop people people from
coming illegally into this country over
the southern border into places like
california where i live normally i i
think you'd be very hard-pressed to stop
guns from coming across that border
illegally as well i mean california has
some of the
have an strictest i know not every
american who would you stop i would stop
anyone with a criminal background i
would stop anybody with a history of
mental illness and i would stop and i
would ask and not ask i would require
that people who have somebody who has a
criminal background or a history of
mental illness in the household keep
that gun locked up and safe
what about the background checks forty
percent of all
uh gun sales in america now gun trades
are not covered by background i believe
in background checks for everybody for
everybody so there should be a database
a national register uh if it's not
public i don't like what happened with
the journal news putting out gun permits
which allows criminals to target
particular homes
when the nra came out today after the
meeting with the white house and just
he's so ready
so
wait
what did the
journal do
oh um i don't know i think he said
like basically if the criminals know who
has the guns and who doesn't they can
target different homes that don't so uh
journal put this information out yeah i
guess
the audacity the audacity
what bro the left is crazy this is what
i told you when you started working here
i'm like look at it this might come with
problems i'm telling you the left is
crazy
i i agree
with
what ben
is saying i don't know if it's
disrespectful just to call him ben like
yeah i call him back i'm like what up
man i feel like we're homeless
but i do think that there needs to be
more screening for everybody whether
you're in law enforcement or whether
you're just a regular person that wants
to get a gun i think there needs to be
more
steps into going that goes into
someone getting a gun there's a show
that i was watching on netflix this boy
he's
maybe like 12 13 he has this like
fixation with death and animals and
whatnot
and
the older boy or someone that he works
with went in and bought a gun for him
and brought it out he said here you go
here's the gun and it's just like it's
that easy
wow i don't know i haven't really
thought about how i would do it like if
we were to change the gun laws
but
to me there's already so much regulation
on guns
i think it should be easier than it is
in like chicago
yeah but i think there should be a
mental health screening oh i agree with
that for sure because
you
yeah i do think that there should be
a mental health screening for
guns just more steps it shouldn't be as
easy as it is to get a gun you shouldn't
walk in there and be like
hey i'd like to buy another oh wait i
don't think it's that easy really no
you're from california you live in
california it is not that easy in
california
i i don't know yeah i think they just
i don't know maybe they're gonna look in
the comments
do your research it's so easy
let me know let me know in the comments
guys
how easy is it to get a gun what state
do you live in and how easy is it to get
a gun there you go
when the nra came out today after the
meeting with the white house and just
said we're just not prepared to
entertain effectively any kind of
new gun restrictions
what do you think of that what's
astonishing to me is the left attack on
the nra because the nra is they don't
receive a dime of public dollars they're
not they're they're an interest group i
don't see you know it's funny the left
they like to talk also about violent
video games for example framing is left
or right because i don't have a horse in
the race i'm gonna vote either way
you tend to be more to the left we all
understand the nra as you know are a
very active and well-funded and powerful
body and what they do why are you asking
i just want to finish the point
this is
very quick i promise the the point that
i'm making is this there's a lot of been
a lot of talk by a lot of people about
video game violence i haven't seen david
gregory interviewing the head of the
aclu and saying it's your broad
interpretation of the first amendment
that's responsible for this but people
are bringing on the nra and saying it's
your broad interpretation of the second
amendment that's responsible for this
they're an interest group if you want
legislation passed talk to legislators
don't worry don't go to an end
here's what the nra and people like alex
jones and others do don't let me in with
alex jones fine after each of these
massacres they come out uh all the gun
rights supporters come up very strongly
and very vociferously
and they basically instill fear they say
if everyone in the movies
if everyone in the movie theater had
been armed if everyone at the school had
been armed it wouldn't have happened and
here's what happens
gun sales and ammunition sales rocket as
we've seen in the last three weeks oh
don't pass the buck piers i mean the
truth is that the reasons
that the reason that people are buying a
lot of guns right now appears is because
people on the left so you see that he
moved the goal post again
you see because then he's like okay well
after a mass shooting then you guys say
this and like don't don't people buy
more guns after a mass shooting but he's
not answering the questions he's asking
okay so he's moving the goal post he's
talking around him and not answering
they're talking very much about banning
guns and so a lot of people are saying
if i can't if i'm not going to have the
right to buy purchase a weapon of my
choosing in two months i'm going to go
and buy it now this is very clear why
does ronald reagan want these assault
weapons removed you know i don't know
why ronald reagan one of these are you a
bit of a you like reagan right i like
reagan in a lot of ways he's not a god i
don't agree with him on everything did
you agree with him he also believed in
the progressive tax rate i don't believe
in that did you agree about assault
weapons um
if i believe what you're saying sure i i
don't believe i don't know
weapons i don't know what his position
on assault weapons was let me read the
letter and sure this was a letter that
he penned along with presidents ford and
carter in 1994 to congress while we
recognize that assault weapon
legislation will not stop all assault
weapon crime statistics prove that we
can dry out the supply of these guns
making them less accessible to criminals
we'd urge you to listen to the american
public and to the law enforcement
community in support of ban on the
further manufacture of these weapons
that was ronald reagan okay so
i can disagree with ronald reagan you
keep framing to the left right now
how is this election one of the great
right-wing presidents of modern times
agreed with me
so so it's not left or right is it no i
mean it unless you deliberately that
word okay the way that the nra through
the 80s and 90s and this last year is
avoiding the breakdown of left hand
right
as a left-wing attack on the american
constitution and the second amendment
exactly what you've tried to do you come
in you brandish your little book
sir
if you
my opinion my opinion sir if you knew
what the constitution was i've been
debating on this for a long time you can
be debating something and never know
what it's talking about
but the fact that he
he brought you the book to
know what it's about because of the
facts you're saying are incorrect sir
i don't even know the whole constitution
and
i'm american and i'm like
bro don't say that a lot
i know it for like
we roughly know it
yes
we're western women okay yes
i i know it
yeah
is
he
i would have said my answer would have
been not well apparently
yeah like
i'm not gonna claim oh i know the
constitution front back back in front
got a tattooed on my arm but i know it
well enough to be a citizen of the
country but it's
i don't like
interviews that are
like you talk let them respond
and if you don't agree with it cool
ask another question
but just to
go
go back and forth like this and you try
to
try to like
uh low blow somebody into oh they shook
they shake it's like
what is journalism nowadays
what's that i just think journalists
should be open like they can't act like
they're unbiased but everyone's biased
yeah
everyone is everyone everyone who's
grown grew up a certain way around
certain people and heard certain things
how can you say you're unbiased every
everyone is dying i'd be lying if i came
on here and i pretended not to be a
conservative yeah
yeah
you'd be like that's me that's right but
i think it comes whenever everyone can
have their bias but it comes to a point
where it's like is your bias
just
truth for your whole life are you going
to actually like sit down and like
listen to people and like see like
your world isn't the only one that's
living here so yeah i've been debating
this for a very long time then you
should read the second amendment i know
the second amendment what i haven't
heard is one coherent reason why any
civilian in america needs an ar-15
military-style assault weapon tell me
why you need one i told you why why the
general population of america law
abiding citizens why do they need those
weapons they need them for the
prospective possibility of resistance to
tyranny which is not a concern today it
may not be a concern
to come from it could come from the
united states because governments have
gone tyrannical before this is not how
did you silence this here's where you go
into the absurd and the bullying you're
absurd you're stupid i understand that
i'm not the one that came in here and
accused you
of standing on the graves of dead
children because you're the one who's
doing that bullying punching back twice
as hard you know what i call it step
punching back twice as hard in the in
the presidency that's what i call
bullying
he was just like oh this is astonishing
and
oh if i was pierced right now i would
want to
not come out because he just has a
little smirk on his face but it's like
what he's saying it's like
morgan pierce sir
listen
like you may not you may not agree
with what he's saying but just just
listen
imagine the producers behind the camera
because that would be i'll just be like
i would forget that i was actually like
filming a show and i'd be like oh sorry
i forgot to change the camera i would
forget it
for weeks now you have been saying that
anybody who disagrees with your position
is absurd idiotic and doesn't care about
the dead kids in sandy hook and then
when i say that that's a bully tactic
you turn around and say i'm bullying you
for saying that it's absurd it's
ridiculous
let me ask you again
what is the point of a civilian having
an ar-15 assault weapon the point of a
civilian having an ar-15 assault weapon
many of them are ex-military right i
mean i have military friends and i have
no pro i don't have a problem with colin
powell owning an ar-15 assault weapon
owning them it depends on the civilian
if it's a criminal they shouldn't do it
no forget criminals and mentally no but
that's it you can't recap
an average
why do they need one to project against
the possibility of eventual government
tyranny this was the purpose of the
second amendment originally it remains
the purpose of the second amendment now
and pretending that governments have
never gone usurpatious before from a
dimension
your own government is going to turn on
you in a way that you require you may
not turn ar 15 to challenge them when
you really believe they may not turn on
me it may not turn down my children
it may not turn on me may not turn on my
children but the fact is this history is
replete with democracies going
tyrannical it has happened it happened
in france in the 19th century it
happened in spain in the last century it
happened in germany it happened in italy
it has happened repeatedly throughout
japan the reason we cannot remove ar-15
assault weapons is because the threat of
your own government turning on you in a
tyrannical way it is yes it is because
your position is because there are
accounts prevailing rights and
responsibilities
i don't understand why
why can't you talk about reasonable
because you want to talk about the issue
you have made your point crystal clear
people aren't stupid they can make up
their own minds then shape
what he said that people aren't stupid
they can make up their own mind
yeah with this it sounds like
just his point at the end people people
aren't stupid they can make up their own
mind then why are you
not letting him speak going so hard to
try to change his mind yeah when in the
end you say people are stupid they can
make up their own mind so why didn't you
just have like a conversation with him
back and forth hearing what he got to
say here's what you have to say
if people are stupid in the end they're
going to make up their own mind i think
it's because he's just mad he lost
i can understand that when people when
people get upset and debate some matter
you could be talking about
something being a certain color and they
are like no it's it's this and if they
losing a debate they start
going off
at the mouth but i can
i can understand what ben is saying
i personally i don't like guns i went to
a shooting range once haven't been back
i i just don't
it's just a lot that goes into a gun and
i'm just like i don't like it but
the steps that he's saying that need to
be taken for
things to be better i would agree with
that that there does need to be mental
health screenings i don't think
criminals should have it and i think
that there um
what was the other
he gave another
step or just more
more steps into controlling the people
that have it and don't have it i can i
can understand him there and understand
what he's saying about the
government and the government taking
over and going into tyranny
um
that's something that personally i've
never like thought about or like worried
about
and so i'm just like because we we grew
up in such a what do you call it
privileged society
like but most of human history you had
to worry about that apparently yeah did
we meet like tribes would take over each
other
that is true like if you didn't have
anything to protect yourself yeah so
like yeah throughout human history
like that was always a fear we just we
got really lucky with when we were born
could have been born 500 years ago for
civil war
knocking somebody out in the civil award
actually i probably wouldn't have been
in this
i'd be like you know what i'll be in the
kitchen
i'll be checking it up in the kitchen
there's another thing you think about
feminism is a rich person
problem because whenever there's war we
are running back to the goddamn kitchen
i'm not trying to fight uh for sure i'm
not near as [ __ ] but i'm not trying to
fight no but think about it from you are
rich when it comes to global history
perspective even poor people didn't have
air i mean okay we're in europe now but
like in the us i'm sure you had air
conditioning
even poor people didn't even know sorry
rich people didn't have air conditioning
like 150 years ago wow
man that's crazy so when you think about
it like people that are ranked in the
lowest income today have a higher
standard of living than people did in
most of history
like poor people have tvs
yeah yeah in that wild yeah they say
that poor people and
our homeless people in california are
more privileged than homeless people
like
in the south or like back east i'm like
dang there's privilege to being homeless
yeah that's crazy
i've seen some of the houses on the
sidewalk
yeah but if you like the video today
make sure you like it make sure you
comment subscribe sign up for
memberships and if you've seen one or
two
or more videos
on this channel
and you haven't subscribed
we got b
b b it doesn't take a lot to just hit
that subscribe button we're entertaining
people
okay okay guys
so would you wait before we end it would
you say
that you agree with guns being legal
or you still think they should all be
illegal it's okay i won't say they
should all be legal but i don't think
people should have access to
the
the military
but you'll be okay with handguns being
legal
no
okay
we'll work on her some more